[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker cbs westwood one color
analyst joining us on the program he's
in miami for the eagles and the dolphins
that'll be tomorrow night
um all right help me understand this
when you first see the video of aaron
donald what do you think
actually dan it just brings back
memories for me um i actually my second
year in the nfl i don't know if i ever
told you this before but i got in a
fight with levar arrington
and i thought i was getting the better
of the fight i was hitting him in the
helmet really hard and i thought i kind
of had him in a headlock next thing i
know levar got my helmet off
and he swung it at me as hard as he
could and i didn't have a helmet on
and that could have been real real bad
uh thankfully he missed
but what's crazy dan just to let people
know the culture a little bit the guys
came over to break up the fight
so they're all like pinning our arms
down you know my arms are pinned lavar's
arms are pinned
somehow he gets his right arm out and
gives me a right hook to the side of my
head blood just comes streaming out i'm
out for one play my offensive line coach
is mad at me because i lost the fight
i go back into practice the whole rest
of practice i just have red blood coming
down
from my ear
i go in after practice i'm 23 years old
dan
and um they put three stitches in the
top of my ear because he split the top
of my ear put three stitches in they
x-rayed my hand my hand was so bruised
from punching his helmet they thought i
might have broke my hand and i'll never
forget
i called my wife dan who was my
girlfriend at the time on the way home
from practice and i said how was your
day and she's like oh you wouldn't
believe it at lunch stacy said blah blah
blah blah blah whatever she said right
and uh she said well how was your day i
said well
kind of a tough day i almost died i got
stitches in my ear and i almost broke my
hand but tell me more about what stacy
said at lunch
what led to the altercation with lavar
arrington
great question um he didn't like the
fact that they were putting him at
defensive end a lot and i had played
poorly on a monday night against the
eagles and i knew i was on the hot seat
i knew i was on the bubble i knew i
could get cut at any moment so i was
practicing really hard and you know the
starters
don't like when the scout team guys or
the backups are are going really hard
they don't like that i don't i don't
blame them i didn't like it when i was a
starter but
i have a lot of friends from high school
and college i didn't need levar
arrington as a friend i needed to try to
keep that job so he kept saying to me
tuck i'm telling you and i was like dude
do what you gotta do so literally before
the play then he's on the end of the
line of scrimmage
i knew we were gonna get in a fight
because i knew i had to block him i knew
he was gonna be mad and i grabbed him
and he just started swinging
and i think often when stuff when the
aaron donald thing happens i think often
like what would have happened if he
connected with that helmet i mean it
would have changed both of our lives
forever those things
especially at that point are like 10 to
12 pound weapons and with a guy that
strong swinging it as violently as he
did it's one thing if you hit a guy in a
helmet it's even another thing if you
swing a helmet at someone that has a
helmet on but if you swing a helmet as
someone that doesn't have a helmet on
that's that's a very very very scary
scenario all right the nfl has responded
to us by saying that the rams are
responsible for overseeing conduct of
their players at practice including
joint practices
what if anything will sean mcveigh and
the rams do
he has to do something and if he doesn't
the nfl should do something they need to
send a message somehow some way that
this is unacceptable you just can't be
swinging helmets at guys i thought you
made a good point dan maybe not the best
idea to have the two teams that just
played in the super bowl and the bengals
players have been thinking about this
every second of every day since they
lost the super bowl they got a chip on
their shoulder like what do you think is
gonna happen in that scenario um but i
think it's a little bit of a cop out by
the nfl that might be what the rule is
dan it's on video it's on video right
like the laura arrington thing nobody
ever heard about it that's on video with
aaron donald at a minimum the rams
should find aaron donald i mean they
just gained like 30 million dollars a
year they can find him some amount or
you know maybe they'll do something damn
where they suspend them for next week of
practice when they don't really need him
to practice anyway he doesn't feel like
practicing it'll probably be something
light but they have to do something
because i think they need to send a very
strong message to kids at every level
that it's not okay you can't take
helmets off and swing them that's as
scary as it gets on a football field
yeah but if if you're miles garrett you
got an indefinite suspension turned out
to be i think six games so the
difference between this is a joint
practice well
okay it's a regular season game it's
still
the act of swinging a helmet it's the
same act it's just one's in the
a real game and one's in a joint
practice
in fairness to the nfl
this might happen other times dan we
just don't see it you know because it's
not when it's not a joint practice or
it's not when the cameras are on for the
news outlets and obviously if it's just
the team they're not gonna let anybody
know about it so i understand the
perspective of we can't be policing what
happens in practice because we don't see
what happens in every practice but you
know how this happens behind the scenes
dan the nfl is going to say something to
the rams like you got to do something to
him you have to do something to him i
don't think he'll be he's not going to
miss an actual regular season game but
maybe some type of
one week suspension from practice and a
500 000 fine they need to do something
otherwise we'll keep talking about it
people will keep saying boy that's a bad
look for the rams so they'll do
something i think just to kind of get
everybody off their back yeah just
wondering about this that we always talk
about the optics here it looks bad but
you're aaron don what would lead aaron
donald to get to that point if this is
in domic and sue then i might go okay
he's got a history of this
like i just went this aaron donald how
do you get in a situation like this that
you let the bengals get to you
well aaron donald has more of a history
of this than people realize if you look
at you know what's happened in some
games he's been in and he's not he's not
to shoes level but aaron allen does not
mess around uh and what happens is dan
is
and this is one of the issues with the
joint practice or just even practice in
general
i
and a lot of guys are like me i was
always going to push the envelope of
what was allowed or not right like i
would rather have the coaches yell at me
tucker calm down tucker don't do that
don't be so rough or don't be so
rather than having to say tucker play
harder
if the coaches are telling you to relax
or calm down that's a good thing so i
can tell you right now what happened
there's interior linemen for the bengals
trying to make sure the rams know things
have changed we got ted kerris in here
we got alex kappa in here you know we
we've got some new linemen lyell collins
and i think they probably did something
that donald thought went over the line
whether it was dirty whether it was late
donald wasn't happy about it and he lost
his cool because he's thinking this is
my livelihood and these guys are trying
to beat the you know what out of me in a
practice it it happens not the swinging
of the helmets doesn't happen a lot but
that level of frustration happens a lot
talking to ross tucker cbs westwood one
color analyst former nfl player and host
of the ross tucker football podcast he
is uh in miami he's got the eagles and
the dolphins
that's tomorrow night are the dolphins
going to be healthy enough to field a
team
well i hope so yeah i got down here
yesterday i flew down yesterday dan i go
to the joint practice and there's no
dolphins so i think i went to the first
ever eagles only practice at the miami
dolphins facility in nfl history i'm
guessing by the way can i just ask you
something how do people live down here
dan i will never complain about the heat
or humidity in pennsylvania ever again
the rest of my life do you see what i'm
holding right here in my hand
okay this is one of my daughter's baby
cloths it looks like it's little koala
bears
i wouldn't survive without this thing
just a little piece of cloth because
otherwise my whole face is drenched it
is so hot down here i can't believe
people live down here sorry for the heat
diatribe boy let's hope the dolphins can
play
in
90
or minus five
minus five
minus five you can put layers on and
here's the thing
when it's minus five
as cold as that is when you're playing
against like a really good player you're
more concerned about him than you are
how cold it is when it's this hot i mean
it's just miserable you feel like you're
dragging
you know what but the thing is dan for a
lot of these guys i heard i saw mike
mcdaniel the new dolphins coach said
this last night for a lot of these guys
tomorrow night's game
it's the most important game of their
life people don't realize that there's
there's i don't know five to ten guys
that are on the edge either of roster
practice squad or practice squad and
going back to podunk mississippi
and never playing football again even
practice squad this year dan is 11 500
a week and you're still in it you know
you're 22 you're 23 this is you put
everything in your whole life into it
you have 32 snaps tomorrow night or
tonight for the other games to decide
whether or not they say yeah let's keep
this kid for 11 500 a week or
no he's not good enough and he goes back
to his hometown where he's probably the
best athlete that's ever come from there
and all of his buddies and his friends
and family like what are you gonna do
now and he's like
i i don't know i don't know it's it's
you you want to talk about pressure
there's a lot of pressure on young men
tonight and tomorrow night what's it
like to get cut
uh really really tough uh and it
happened to me four times so you're
talking kind of an expert on on getting
cut
um
each one was different
but what's really unique gosh i'm gonna
like my eyes are gonna fill up here you
know
especially if you're from like a small
town like me
it's not just about you you know it's
like
you feel like not only did you let
yourself down
but
you let all the people that live
vicariously threw you down
and it makes it really hard really hard
because the other thing too is for a lot
of these guys you know how there's
always those guys there that are like
i'm so much more than just a football
player football is what i do but it's
not who i am i was never like that
i am a football player i'm a football
meathead i'm an ivy league football
vanderbeek meathead or whatever they
call me okay i like the people said
there's ross tucker the football player
i like that that was my identity so when
i was cut and i knew i was really done
that that that took a lot out of me i
you know i just went crazy then i i went
from 310
to 248 in like four months
because i had so much
anxiety
mental issues i just poured myself into
losing weight because
i was no longer the football player i
was no longer you know if i go somewhere
hey there's ross tucker the football
player and i felt like i had lost my
identity and for a lot of these guys
that's what they lose it's what they've
been doing since they were little it's
what everyone's always known as and then
this isn't golf this isn't tennis this
isn't basketball you can't ever play it
again once it's over it's over it's a
light switch and the light never comes
back on
and you bring up a great point it's your
identity it's been your identity for 15
20 years small town oh man he's really
good oh he's going to play next level oh
he's going to play in the nfl and then
when you get cut and you come back home
and then you have to answer those people
saying
what happened
i almost wish when i went back that i
had a t-shirt
that said you know thanks
not sure yet
i'll let you know you know what i mean
because everybody's like and honestly
it's so weird dan because every time you
go back to your hometown people are
always like hey ross what's up man i saw
you on tv hey ross how you doing but
after you get cut they don't know how to
act in they don't know what to say you
know what do you say to the guy that
you've always been like hey ross it's
awesome but then he just got fired and
like you don't know
it's like a series of awkward
interactions but do you cry right away
when you get cut is it okay to cry
when you get cut
uh i think it is okay to cry when you
get cut um
i'm trying to think
the
the third the first time i got cut i was
upset just it was the first time the
second time it was parcells and i was
just shocked
the third time it was the bills
and i called my best friend
and i cried because i had just gotten
married
and my wife had left her job on wall
street in new york to move with me in
buffalo so here i am i just got married
in may
it's august
and now uh me getting cut was not only
affecting my life it was affecting you
know my favorite person my wife's life
and i call my best friend and i i really
that one really hurt
because i i felt like
me getting hurt or whatever
um was ruining somebody else's life or
was adversely affecting the life of
someone that i love it's a lot man it's
heavy guy dan i didn't know you're gonna
ask me all this stuff man
well it's good to talk to you as always
always thank you so much for having me
all right and have fun in miami don't go
outside just
stay inside i have to go to the wall i
gotta go to the eagles walk through
right now but i got my koala bear piece
of cloth i'll be good
is there pollen in the air your eyes are
all red
no it's just the sun is that what it is
[Laughter]
you're not gonna cry are you no no no
i'm good i'm good okay
why don't you go hit somebody why don't
you go hit lavar arrington
that's i would love to that's the beauty
of football is if you're frustrated okay
if you saw lavar arrington
would you say anything
about the moment but okay oh yeah no
i've seen no i i've told this story
before like on on my show and stuff he
knows i talk about it and he's always
like talk because because it's not a
good look for him but it's okay we're
actually friends that's fine honestly
now it's just a good story but is there
somebody if you saw them
you'd want to hit them
um yeah but it's total it's not a
football guy it's uh it's ross from
friends because what he did to the name
david schwimmer the actor
just being such a dweeb
just he really i mean i was in high
school dan when friends was popular and
he was like
rachel rachel why don't you like me he's
the only actor that like i legitimately
want to punch the guy in the face i know
it's not really him but just because of
what he did to the the esteemed name
that is ross i kind of want to punch him
in the face yeah but he's sorry david
but he got jennifer aniston
not really
did he get her at the end i don't
remember well he could have i think that
they actually had a mutual attraction
for each other
he just seemed like such a sniveling uh
rachel why don't you like me it's like
dude that's why she doesn't like you
because you're a sniffling you're a
sniveling dweeb nerd okay you're
answering your own questions right dude
cross on friends if you run into him
don't hit him all right i won't but i
might have words with him at least okay
thank you ross see you guys yeah do you
think ross from friends looks at ross
tucker goes oh man that meat had he
ruined my life like you know
he's not sensitive you know
well no he is he was crying today